the jurogan experience
so the atlantis one so the rishot
structure i was wondering if you saw
those videos yeah no that was that was a
big one that i saw because i've been
fascinated by the concept of atlantis
you know ever since i had these
conversations with randall carlson and
graham hancock about the younger dryas
impact theory and this concept that
somewhere in the roughly
around 11 000 12 000 years ago we were
hit by a series of comments and it's
pretty evident that that's a fact if you
do the core samples of the earth they
find this nuclear glass all over the
earth that exists in that time period
and it seems like something happened
that reset civilization and there's
very little uh
evidence of advanced civilizations
before that up until recently up until
the last couple of decades they started
uncovering things like cobalt tepe
and all these other structures that are
clearly from
more than 12 000 years ago and they're
really complex and really large with
enormous stones and it's sort of caused
people to rethink the history of the
earth and the history of human
civilizations and atlantis has always
been the big one that has been the one
that everybody talked about was this
incredibly advanced civilization
and no one can figure out where it is
right or if it was real
i think that atlantis because surely
that wouldn't have been necessarily the
name just through like the the change of
language you know over let's say 12 13
000 years ago which would be the time
frame
so like surely there would be several
different changes of language but i
think it represented a civilization that
was doing great things they were more
global than what many people think would
be possible
um
it atlantis was said to be a kingdom
made up of or an empire excuse me made
up of ten kingdoms and then there was
the lost city of atlantis which was the
capital which was said to be made up of
concentric circles uh
two of water three of land
and
essentially that they were obliterated
by a cataclysm as passed down by plato
although it's worth mentioning that
plato got the story of atlantis from
solon who was his
uh uncle separated by six generations
but what people most people don't
realize is that solon had traveled to
egypt and so it's the ancient egyptians
is where that tale comes from
which makes it even more bizarre because
i would argue that the most spectacular
ancient civilization is the egyptians i
mean no disrespect to the romans hard to
deny right i mean
let me just say because i want to on
this podcast encourage people to travel
to egypt it joe you got to go
i really want to a friend of mine just
went and she got back and she was
telling me incredible things about it
jamie we pull up the photos of these
concentric circles tell him yeah the
wrist shot
r-i-c-h-a-t it's worth mentioning that
yeah in the first couple
i just want to say it's wrist shot i
used to call it rick hot i was
mispronouncing it but let me ask you
this joe real quick
when you saw my video was that the very
first time you had ever seen this thing
before yeah that's the thing
so many when i first saw this i was like
what the [ __ ] is that by the way you see
that white all those white blemishes
that's salt
this was under the ocean and people
let me just say you mentioned randall
carlson and graham hancock i love them
and i know for sure that they don't
particularly think this is the site for
a few different reasons
um so let me say there's absolute doubt
even i am not 100 certain i'm not even
100 certain that lance's existed what i
am certain is that humans were doing
spectacular things in a civil uh you
know a cataclysmic event happened called
the younger dryas and reset something
for somebody is there a natural
explanation for this formation yes so
what so let me say that it is considered
to be a mysterious they don't they're
not a hundred percent certain of it
however the consensus is that it was a
volcanic dome that had risen and
collapsed multiple times like 100
million years ago allegedly i don't i
say allegedly i'm not necessarily
disagreeing with that i'm just saying i
would like to know where sometimes they
get these figures from like explain to
me why it was 100 million years ago and
not 99 or 98 because here we are talking
about how crazy things changed in just
the last 12 13 000 years so when they
throw around these numbers
you know one million years in itself is
an incredibly long period of time but
getting back to your question
some had originally thought that maybe
it was an impact site from a crate from
a you know an asteroid or perhaps but
there's no evidence for it like there's
none of them the problem is is there's
these concentric circles
i like i've never seen anything i mean
obviously i'm not an archaeologist but
i've never seen anything like this
in
i mean if you study structures that are
like man-made structures i've never seen
anything like this that humans have made
but i've definitely never seen like any
go to that one where your curse is yeah
jamie please
so is this
you want to see some all right
okay okay one one step at a time because
we also have to take into consideration
that people are just listening so kind
of describe what we're looking at here
okay so what you're looking at is
approximately 250 miles inland in the
total barren desert of mauritania africa
so the western image looks like why is
it blue that's just showing you what it
used to look like no this is what it
looks like right now through i forgot
what you call this type of animation but
it's essentially it's a satellite
imagery that they enhanced in order for
you to see the difference in elevation
and the actual structure to itself okay
so it like if there was water in this
area you would see it this way that it
would be these concentric circles that
are raised above the water and then the
water would be inside of it like that
well just to clarify this particular
image no this is not trying to represent
water so that blue is actually picking
up on salt so
salt all that was salt but i mean it
used to be underwater right it's well
because it was underwater
that's what i believe and that's what
makes the most sense to me others will
disagree and let me tell you why it is
currently 12 1300 feet above sea level
it's 250 miles inland and so some people
say this was never under the ocean at
least not for the last tens of millions
of years is what the scientists claim
i argue that since the salt is still
there and not only that jamie if you go
to the other images that show you more
of the the white
the one uh that you were previously on
the one to the middle to the left right
there
so
those areas with the most white
blemishes happen to be the areas that
are the lowest in elevation which to me
tells me that saltwater had settled
there but not only that joe atlantis was
said to be like we said you know
multiple rings of you know water and
land
however it was said to open to the sea
to the south and what you're looking at
here that
the south so this is oriented north
south east and west what do you see to
the south especially if you could get
another this is very flat area that
looks like it's the lowest elevation
like around it looks like it's higher i
mean it's hard to tell from this image
jamie will you will you google map it
just type in um even if you went to
moretania so you could see this from
space
astronauts use it as a locator and they
weren't really familiar or aware of it
until the gemini missions in the early
1960s so if you go to like if you just
go to google earth you could you'll be
able to find this quite quickly it
stands out and it's why they call it the
eye of africa or the eye of the sahara
all right so just pan out a little bit
and it'll provide us with a much yeah
keep going
all that all that white is salt in fact
i have a friend josh and they went out
there and tasted that [ __ ] off the
[ __ ] ground that's salt because a lot
of people say this was never under the
ocean and i'm like all right you see all
that even randall carlson himself which
let me just say he for a few reasons
doesn't he he favors the azores he
doesn't think this is likely to be
location for a few reasons favors what
the azores the the uh island chained
which would be
uh it's it's and he thinks that that was
atlantis he to him he's partial towards
that um but
so he analyzed this site and you see all
the striations how it looks like the the
ocean or so that's all water erosion joe
and if you scroll in so remember when
randall was on your show and he showed
you the mizzou of missoula floodplains
and all those giant ripples from the
huge current that it went through
this this is here so scroll in right
there where your cursor is jamie
the
yeah scroll right in
you're going to see those same water
ripples keep going because this what
you're looking at here is panned up this
is many miles like keep in mind this
structure is 30 miles crazy that looks
like the bottom of the ocean like if you
see where the water breaks on on the
sand yep and i have uh wow
and that just to clarify that salt or
excuse me that white is salt and that is
the because that's a lot of people don't
know joe that the sauer desert wasn't a
thing until approximately 5 000 years
ago it's only in the last several years
and by the way i'm quoting mit research
here that the sahara goes back and forth
from green to desert approximately every
20 000 years
uh they believe it has something to do
with the earth's tilt and that's worth
discussing
but
so this whole area because people are
like well that's not atlantis i'm like
well first of all if this whole if the
western or excuse me the sahara desert
was a lush green tropical paradise which
had the largest known freshwater lakes
ever known to have existed for example
uh mega lake chad which is
it's like three times more water surface
than all of the um north american great
lakes combined
big sucker oh [ __ ] how is it not an
ocean
i know fresh water it was when it
existed and that was at the time when
the sahara was green and it also had
some of the largest known rivers exist
that they were known to have existed
throughout the world i think they'd
still be ranked 10th today or something
like that but
um so you have to when you see this
people have to imagine that this area
was once green and that if that because
one of the arguments i make is that the
fact that that salt is on top of that
dirt to me is indicative that the ocean
flowed over here far more recently than
what people think how wide is this
structure okay so concentric circles i
meant to bring i brought a laser do you
have a laser pointer in here no it's
okay so this the circles themselves
is about 14
and a half miles across however if you
go the complete shebang the whole circle
itself is just shy of 30 miles
so the whole thing is 30 miles which
would be like the size of a city
right well well keep in mind the outer
ring would have been water so the so
that wouldn't have necessarily counted
but some people say that this is too big
according to plato's description um and
let me just say that i'm like well hold
on a second i don't think that we should
consider
that
because of loss of translation that we
should consider the measurements a key
detail the question becomes is it big
enough to be a city with possibly
millions of people because the way it
was described
is that it was a city that was said to
be busy all day all night rich in trade
with languages spoken from all over so
i'm like okay
it would that would imply millions of
people i mean if a city's busy all day
and all night i think of large
metropolitan areas like new york chicago
london whatever
and so if this
if this was indeed an ancient
or a site of an ancient civilization
well then it would have i mean they're
obviously not going to have skyscrapers
so it would have to be an area big
enough to sustain that many people and
the rich shot structure certainly does
and so the idea would be that this would
lead out to the ocean and that these
circles would be where the water is and
the ridges would would be where the
structures are where the the houses and
the buildings are yeah and people will
say well where is that stuff now i'm
like well look at it it got i was
obliterated yeah those people should
shut the [ __ ] up well let's just look at
what's going on with the sand and those
clear water erosion marks on the sand
but that also could be wind right
couldn't the way that the ripples and
that that sand couldn't that be wind
both however just to
this is just sand that is the where the
cursor's at right there yeah that's all
sand however the uh it's also actually
go
uh to the right where it says layers
jamie can you scroll in right there
because that will show you the ripples
more so it's a combination of sand and
rock you mean to the betweens
right there that's what i'm talking
about those are giant ripples and i'm
quoting let me just say i'm quoting
randall carlson who i consider to be an
expert on these on geological formations
and so
um
yeah
right but
isn't that what wind-driven sand looks
like if you go to dunes dunes look like
that yeah and undoubtedly but hold on
this is sand right yes well it's
combination rock and sand in between
right but this is like what it would
look like if wind driven sand and rock
underneath it right so what the
implication is that it was blasted by
water and then after that the wind has
done its thing and moved the sand all
over it and in between so 20 000 years
ago this was all green lush
yes so i could show you um when do they
think atlantis was is it 11 600 is
allegedly when it was destroyed which
here's the younger driest climate
catastrophe because um
so plato had so this is 600 bc and plato
said that it happened 9 000 years
earlier so that would be 11 600 years
ago which coincides with the younger
driest climate catastrophe which makes
it so compelling to me that is
actual scientific evidence that
indicates that atlantis actually existed
because it's very specific it is very
specific but it's not scientific right
it's like there's no real evidence okay
let me rephrase that a civilization yes
let me rephrase a civilization got
[ __ ] yeah 11 600 so never mind
atlantis let me rephrase a civilization
was around this the stories of it were
passed down and they got obliterated so
that's that's what i'm implying well we
all we definitely know that the younger
driest impact theory is
extremely plausible there are without a
doubt
uh
like many many impact part points on
earth where they find this uh tritonite
this nuclear glass which they you can
get either from a nuclear explosion or
you get it from
some sort of a meteor impact large scale
you know all over the continent and we
know that uh all over the planet i
should say we we know that that happened
this is like real hardcore geological
evidence so if we know that there were
structures before that which we do now
because of gobekli tapping and a few
other places that they're reasonably
sure were uh pre 11 000 years ago 12 000
years ago
then we know that something was around
back then that was very sophisticated
how sophisticated we don't know